on évoque souvent les 35 heures mais
sans savoir pour l'instant en quoi l on
me dit phil le comportement des français
anadys peut-être à prendre en compte
avec ce sondage qui affirme que près
d'un salarié sur deux achète davantage
grâce à la réduction du temps de travail
le nom de journées chômées au mois de
mai en raison des nombreux week end
devrait un peu plus encore alimenter les
résultats de cette étude
chris 9 des dards et frédéric bazille si
les files d'attentes s'allongent dans
les grands magasins
c'est aussi grâce aux 35 heures voilà le
principal constat de ce sondage
premier bénéficiaire les produits
culturels
46% des sondés affirment avoir fait plus
d'achats dans ce domaine hausse des
dépenses aussi pour les voyages et les
vacances pour 43% des personnes
interrogées
enfin 40 2 % des sondés se sont tournés
vers l'équipement de leur logement et
les sorties les 35 heures auraient pu
être une catastrophe pour la
consommation s'il y avait eu réduction
du pouvoir d'achat
mais comme la plupart des accords 35
heures sauf avec maintien du pouvoir
d'achat donc ya pas eu cet effet là en
prime il ya évidemment le million de
salariés qui ont retrouvé un emploi qui
auront du pouvoir d'achat pour consommer
c'est pour ça que dans la situation
actuelle les 35 heures sont
effectivement favorables la consommation
plus de temps libre égal plus d'achats
que dire alors du mois de mai grâce aux
ponts et aux jours d'euros pour poser
ici ou là certains vont bénéficier de 13
jours de congés pour deux semaines de
travail
la consommation devrait donc être ans
pendant cette période
à moins que le mauvais temps s'en mêle
depuis quelques semaines on voit que la
consommation est très réactive à la
météo donc ça va beaucoup dépendre de ce
qui va se passer s'il fait par exemple
plutôt bon on va se précipiter vers son
jardin pour les gens qui en ont et ça va
faire un boom dans les jardineries
si l inverse le mois de mai continuent
est pourri comme le mois précédent et
bien là ça fera beaucoup moins de
dépenses dans ce domaine
mais c'est d'abord les professionnels du
tourisme qui devrait profiter de ce mois
de mai depuis quelques jours ils
multiplient les offres de court séjour
en france comme à l'étranger